So, widget animations.
It's worth just kind of like breaking this down a little bit.
We've already seen the widget animation window,
but it's just worth highlighting that the widget animation system
is essentially a reimplementation of the sequencer.
So for anyone who's not familiar with sequencer,
sequencer is Unreal's kind of cinematic authoring tool.
It replaced the previous cinematic authoring tool,
which was called Matinee, back in like,
four-sixteen, I'm going to say.
Don't quote me on that.
And that, you know, over, it started off as with many things,
it's an experimental tool and has gained more functionality
and has become kind of more performant
and more kind of stable over time.
And at some points they introduced that as a,
you didn't used to be able to author widget animations
using sequencer, but that's been introduced.
So when we're talking about widget animations,
typically we're talking about the implementation,
the kind of sequencer-esque implementation.
It is not the only way to author animations within a widget.
You can essentially code your animations,
which is actually slightly more performant.
But this is kind of the easiest, most graphical,
most probably user-friendly way to control things.
And it gives us a lot of animation-like control.
So for any animators who want their kind of like nice curves
and to kind of really control all the kind of blends
and stuff like that, it's quite likely that using
the kind of sequencer implementation of the animation
is really what we're going to be talking about.
So in similar fashion to a sequencer,
each animation is really a collection
of kind of named properties or bindings.
So an animation essentially has bindings
to kind of various entities that it animates.
And each of those entities has various properties,
which are kind of defined by individual tracks.
And those tracks can then be keyed.
So keying is a term that will be familiar to anyone
who's used to a little bit of animation before.
And each of these things can be keyframes.
You specify particular values at particular points,
and then some kind of logic will be used
to blend between those two points over several frames.
Yeah, it's worth mentioning that like particular keyframes
can't be changed at runtime.
So this is more of a kind of like
you're basically authoring animations at editor time here.
There are various techniques that you can utilise
to make these a little bit more dynamic
or possibly reusable and more kind of contextual.
But for the most part, unless you're being a little bit clever
with your blend modes and stuff like that,
you are kind of authoring relatively static information here.
So creating a widget animation,
we've got just a little demonstration
of what a widget animation might look like
in an incredibly high resolution and high frame rate GIF.
But yeah, we're going to do a simple adjustment
of a transform property with an animation.
But obviously the kind of same principles can be layered up
and applied to several animations over time.
So first off, we've got our animation window,
which we've already talked about.
And this is how you would create a new animation.
You just click the new animation button
and then you can just name the animation.
And then if we were to go into our animation,
you can see here that when you click on an animation,
the first thing I want to highlight here
is that we get this little perimeter on the edge.
This is basically a warning that lets you know
that you're currently in an animation mode,
which is quite important to bring up
because any changes you're making whilst this is selected
could be things that you're inadvertently keying
into your animation.
And it might not be information
that you're permanently changing about the widget.
So it's just really worth remembering
that when you're in an animation,
you might not be making permanent changes to your widget.
This might be animation that is specifically applying
to that animation.
I'm just going to quickly jump here
because the GIF is incredibly distracting.
If we actually dock that in the layout,
so we make a new animation.
And you can see as soon as I click that,
I get this border to say, hey, you're in animation mode.
So just try and pay some attention to this.
Obviously, it's meant to be a little bit obnoxious
to kind of really make sure that you know that.
If you want to be sure that you're not accidentally
keying information into your animation,
and as importantly, if not more importantly,
not making the permanent changes
that you might want to be making to your widget,
just click off the animation
and you're no longer trying to write information
into your actual animation.
So then if we were to go into my animation,
I can just basically pick some content to kind of add here.
So I can just go,
if I actually give my images a bit of a name
because this can be a little bit confusing.
This is a general tip that I would say,
it's no different from naming your variables properly
is that for the purposes of animation,
but also for code,
it's kind of good to name your widgets properly
so they can be easily distinguished.
So if I just say like,
I would normally call things like canvas panel underscore roots.
This is a personal naming convention.
This isn't necessarily something that would be used all over Epic.
But then I'm just going to call this image top left.
And I'm going to call this one image center
and just makes them a little bit easier
to distinguish from each other.
So then if I go to right click,
you can see I can add,
this is depending on whatever I've got currently selected.
You can see I can add a kind of entity
that I want to animate here.
So this is going to,
because I currently have image center selected,
I can bind that.
So if I then do that,
you can see if I click on this plus icon here,
so here's our binding.
Here's the thing that we're actually trying to animate.
But then we need to say what kind of like property
about this thing do I want to change?
Do I want to animate its color and opacity?
Do I want to animate its root slot?
So for the purpose of moving this thing,
as we've already said,
the slot is what kind of defines this thing's layout.
And in the context of a canvas panel,
the slot has a lot of control over its pixel coordinates
and stuff like that.
So we'll go and animate the slot.
And then you see we get this kind of sub track.
And this is basically to say
this is data that belongs to this particular entity.
So if I were to similarly keyframe our image top left
and do the same thing at a canvas slot,
you can see the kind of way
that hierarchy is going to be laid out,
that when I'm talking about this one,
this is the slot for this image
and this is the slot for this image.
And similarly, if I were to add something
that's going to define the color and opacity,
that is the color and opacity for this widget.
And if I were to add something like, I don't know,
the visibility track here,
this is going to be the visibility for this image.
So these things are kind of like hierarchical.
We have the entity itself
and then we have the various bits of information
about the entity that we're keyframing.
So then we just select whatever kind of property
that we want to keyframe
and then we just keyframe it essentially.
The easiest way to probably do this
is you'll notice here in our details panel,
we have the kind of various variables available to us
and you'll notice we've got this little icon
that appears on the right.
This essentially represents any bit of information
that is animatable.
So this isn't just an animation frame thing.
The same thing appears here.
You see they're currently kind of grayed out and locked
and that's because we're not in animation.
So keyframing this thing means nothing.
But it's a good way of just taking a quick look
to be like what information would even be keyframable.
This can help when you're kind of designing solutions
to problems to be like,
oh, is it possible that I might be able to use
an animation to adjust this property?
If it doesn't have a little keyframe icon next to it,
then know that that variable is not keyframable.
Worth bearing in mind as well
because it can also answer certain questions for you.
For example, we have color and opacity of this image
that is keyframable.
But if we go to our brush,
our brush's tint isn't keyframable.
So that can actually lead you to certain conclusions
like if you don't want your code,
if you want to be able to tweak the color of something,
but you want an animation that fades that thing in and out
and you're worried that your code
is going to clash with your animation,
bearing in mind that the tint isn't keyframable
and therefore could never be animated,
maybe the tint is what you can be adjusting the color of
and you can rely on the fact that color and opacity
is probably going to be the thing
that you're adjusting for your opacity.
Although on that particular note,
there is also a keyframable value,
which is your render opacity,
which would also specifically keyframe uniquely
for rendering opacity.
So maybe you can avoid that problem entirely there
as well.
So if we were to go to...
There are several different ways to do this.
But if...
Sorry, my computer's suddenly running a bit slowly there.
So if we were to add...
Obviously, our Canvas panel slot itself
has several bits of data within it.
So we wouldn't just want to keyframe the slot entirely.
We have lots of different bits of data.
It can be a little bit confusing in the context
of our Canvas panel slot
because we have these things called anchors, minimum, maximum,
then we have alignment and offsets,
but we're kind of used to seeing position X and Y.
That's because our position X and Y
is actually an offset from whatever our anchor is.
So when we're talking about our position X and Y,
that's actually this offsets value here.
So if I did offsets and I had a keyframe,
you can see our initial keyframe or initial values
are just whatever our standard values are.
They're not yet keyframes.
So this isn't going to be saved
as the beginning of our animation.
So I can just quickly bind a keyframe here
and you can see I have...
I don't know why those aren't actually...
Oh, they are being written in there just for some reason,
not really appearing properly in my animation.
You can control and mouse wheel, by the way,
to kind of zoom in and out on your timeline.
That's a kind of standard sequencer thing
and right click and then to kind of pan.
And if I were to kind of just drop in
another set of keyframes here,
you can now see I get kind of like
a timeline being constructed
and I can go to these keyframes
and either I can edit my values here.
So I could change this to like 2000
and you would see the widget would move to the right
or actually off the edge of my screen here.
Or I could change that in here.
Now it's worth mentioning that when you're making tweaks
inside the editor itself, this is not currently keyframes.
Even though I'm over a keyframe,
I would actually have to choose to bake this change
into my key data by clicking the keyframe button again
and you see that gets updated there.
And now when I scroll back and forth,
you can see that value is actually going to change like this
and then I can also demo it by playing it
and see what it would actually do.
And just if I want to add a little bit more functionality to it,
I could also do some color and opacity stuff.
So I'm just going to over that same timeline,
I'm going to do keyframe, a couple of different things.
I'm going to keyframe my color twice
and I'm going to keyframe it.
I'm going to go to my editor here
and I'm going to go to my current opacity
and I'm going to change it to like red and keyframe that.
And then I'm going to change it to blue here
or I'm going to keyframe that.
And the other thing you can do
is you have like free control over these keyframes
themselves so I can move these back a bit.
You can shrink your overall time.
So you can say this entire,
I'm going to pull back the entire duration of this thing
and you can see that this is,
I can essentially adjust the overall size of my,
that this thing is going to take
so that my keyframes don't necessarily have to take
quite so long.
You can actually scale the keyframes
so that you're kind of shrinking these things
in a percentage way.
But if you just see over there as I'm scrubbing,
it shifts from red to blue.
And if I were to preview this animation, red to blue.
Okay, so I'm keyframing multiple elements together
and I can preview it in a very visual way.
The last thing to mention is that if I,
now that I've got this animation,
you can see clearly I've made some changes
outside of animation time
and that's kind of, some of that stuff
has kind of been either like locked in.
So just worth, it's worth kind of jumping between the two.
Clearly at some point I accidentally changed,
made some change to data
that wasn't actually being baked into my animation
and that's why I'm saying it's very important
to bear these things in mind.
So I'm just gonna set that back to those initial values
that I expected them to be at.
This isn't gonna be affecting the animation,
which we can tell
because we've not got that border on
and now I'm just gonna compile and save that.
So this is our standard starting point
and when I go to my animation,
you can see we,
this is the effect that it has when it plays.
And when I click off it resets back to its defaults.
So that's kind of altering an animation.
The other thing just to kind of mention
is that whenever you're making an animation,
each animation you create
becomes almost like an asset in your user widget,
is unique to this widget.
So this isn't going to your content browser,
this is built into the UMG itself.
And so for every animation that you make,
you would get another entry in your variable section
under animations.
So this can then be used in code,
you can play this animation.
So I'm very quickly gonna demonstrate this.
I'll actually couple together
some of the stuff we've already seen.
So I'm gonna just put a delay.
We don't need to worry about
what construct actually is yet,
but I'm just gonna delay for a second
and then play this animation.
And in my level blueprint,
I'm going to,
I'm gonna make a new level
and I'm just going to go to my level blueprint.
We're gonna create our,
whatever we just called that my new widget,
my view, my new widget.
And we're gonna add that to our viewport.
Again, making it isn't enough,
we actually have to put it on our screen.
So when we begin play,
you can see it will appear in the center of our screen
and then it animates off.
You just have to trust that it's blue
and on the right side of our screen.
But obviously,
because it went off the edge of the canvas,
we can't see it anymore.
So we can see that's all working really nicely.